today's video is brought to you by
summoner's war
boasting over 110 million downloads on
google play in the app store
it's by far one of the best turn based
rpgs on mobile
collect over a thousand monsters and
expand your roster in order to build the
perfect
team bring them to the ever exciting
battles featuring deep strategies
experiment with team compositions and
hone your skills to make your mark in
the mobile esports scene besides the
exciting gameplay and cool graphics
i just love summoners war because of the
constant updates with events
new features and new characters at the
ready the fun just never stops to kick
things up a notch summoner's war is also
having its first collaboration with
street fighter 5.
check out the game and get to see your
favorite street fighter characters like
ryu
chunnily bison and others the good news
well the party's just getting started
summoners wars taking the next step with
an augmented reality filter event
make sure to check that out on summoners
more social media wait no longer
download summoner's war today by
following the link below and get your
free
ken today
battles are a staple in a lot of shonen
anime most of the memorable and iconic
shots that even the most
casual of fans cherish come from these
fights however anime also has one rather
infamous reputation
that is the reluctance to kill off major
characters chances are if you're a named
character with a significant role in a
shonen anime
plot armor will nine times out of ten
save you from doom
this list won't be about those kinds of
fights today we're going over 10 fights
with
lasting consequences that is these are
fights where two people
walk in and only one comes out alive
these are the top 10 anime fights
to the death
we start off with akame versus esder for
a show that pulls no punches in giving
us character deaths like akami gar kill
it would be nothing more than a
disservice to have its climactic battle
between akame and ez death be
anything but a death match for 23
episodes we've seen what the two
fighters are capable of and it's finally
time for the inevitable collision
emotions are running high following
tatsumi's death and both agame and
ezdeth
open right up with their iconic
techniques it seems that the tides have
turned in favour of esdeath who was on
the defensive the majority of the fight
only for her to get struck by a decisive
blow
accepting defeat she then encases
herself in ice with tatsumi and explodes
overall a rather quick fight but it does
have its moments
i mean i personally thought that the way
akame overcame the time freezing skill
was a bit of a plot convenience at least
when i watched it nonetheless the fight
is still a decent way to wrap things up
for what by that point can already be
considered an original series altogether
[Music]
now here's a naruto moment that everyone
will continue remembering for years to
come
in what would eventually become his last
mission jariah runs into pain
however the leader of the enemy forces
isn't what he seems for one pain turns
out not to be just one being
but multiple puppets as expected jeriah
puts up one
hell of a fight he'd just gone through
conan but he didn't even break a sweat
given how well he kept up with the pains
in the first phase of the battle it
seemed that he could even pull it off
or escape however as strong as he may be
even the legendary jiraiya would find
himself falling against sheer numbers
he'd die in battle but not before
passing away with a smile and a peaceful
reassurance to himself
probably one of the more heroic and
heart-wrenching deaths in the series
there's a reason why i consider this
fight one of the top moments in the
entire series
period
[Music]
jyotaro finds itself at number seven on
this list
jojo's craziness doesn't seem to have
limits and all that can be seen in its
full glory in this extended battle much
of giordano's important fights seem to
involve a nemesis from the past
the fan favorite dio their final battle
starts off in a shot that's been forever
immortalized as a meme and they wasted
no time pushing the battle into high
gear the two fighters
seemingly evenly matched take turns
pummeling each other before the world
takes the advantage in the end we even
see jotaro nearly died
an appearance by joseph's soul helps
jotano come back from seemingly
unbeatable odds and reveals a
time-stopping power of his own the fight
gets turned for the last time
the world crumbles and dio's finally
dead after a generation long feud with
the joe stars
amazing fight this so i'm seeing dio
finally get put down after seemingly
being invincible was a sight to behold
never will we have another jojo villain
as charismatic as you
rest well
sixth in line is saitama versus boros
you know given a show like one punch man
it's pretty much impossible to have a
battle with tension isn't it what's
there to be worried about with the kind
of hero that you have in this show this
fight's pretty much
classic one punch man flair world
rending villain showing off their crazy
and over-the-top
powers to much fireworks and fanfare
only to fall at the hands of the
almighty saitama
the visuals do make it seem like boris
could finally be the one to give a
challenge to our bold hero here and
in a way he does it's not like saitama
uses serious punch every day and he does
it here to bring boros down for good the
status quo
doesn't seem to change though but that
doesn't mean that the fights don't look
awesome the fight between saitama and
boros is a classic example of pretty
much a predetermined fight
that still looks every bit amazing
the dark tournament arc is for a lot of
reasons one of the most well remembered
arcs in anime in the 90s it showed the
world how a tournament arc should be
done and it gave us a lot of memorable
fights and villains the climax of the
ark saw yusuke take on toguro with the
former fighting to avenge genkai toguro
dominates the battle after an initial
disadvantage which lasted for just a few
moments and the stakes get raised when
he threatens guava enraged yusuke turns
the tides and lets doguro go into his
ultimate 100
form toguro's overconfidence would be
the end of him as he charges a spirit
gun head-on leading to his muscles
crumbling and his untimely death however
it's not a regrettable death for the
villain as he thanked yusuke for
allowing him to release his full power a
memorable fight with its ups and downs
this fight is just one of the many
reasons why many old school anime fans
look back at the dark tournament arc so
fondly
ichigo has been in many fights to the
death and he's tasted death's doorstep
many times but none of those came as
memorable as the battle against all
kiara in las noches after getting bodied
by orkiora multiple times already ichigo
finally toughened his resolve and set
off to finally rescue orihime for good
thus he charges all kiyora with all of
his strength and
gets bodied again no matter which
power-up he pulls out or whichever
impressive attack
he throws he still finds himself getting
destroyed by the fourth espada at every
turn ending with him pretty much dead by
the end of it however one last power-up
a new form would come out and completely
change the complexion of the battle in
his new form it was ichigo doing the
squashing and he turns the tide so badly
that all kia ora gets a door shut on a
redemption arc attempt ichigo vs all kia
ora is out there in terms of storyline
and stakes but i think that the sheer
destructive power in this battle trumps
almost
everything that bleach had beforehand
it's also one of the most impressive
battles visually
and certainly one of the high points of
the hueco mundo arc
the first of our top three is scar vs
bradley
deep into fma brotherhood scar has
played the rival slash
uneasy ally character pretty well he
freshly turned good but i think that at
this point he still needed a fight that
would put him on the map the fight that
would define him as a character kind of
like the multiple mustang fights that
we've got when everything's said and
done
and luckily for him he gets it right
here an overwhelming strong character
king bradley finally finds his match and
eventually meets his end at the hands of
scar in a key moment in the series he
drives scar
in a corner thanks to his powers but
having lost his ultimate eye
the writing's on the wall for the
homunculus he gets his arms destroyed
before biting it you gotta give bradley
props though
even in death he still manages to
crucially stab scar and get a measure of
revenge what a way for scar to get his
character defining battle in a fight to
the death against
king bradley to boot it was an amazing
feeling to see one of the most
overpowered characters in the series
fall at the hands of scar
[Music]
[Music]
throughout the years the climactic
battle in sword of the stranger has aged
beautifully
in terms of pure spectacle though it's
one of the best sword fights that i've
ever seen
capping off what's been an amazing movie
so far nanashi and luo lang face off in
their final battle inside temple grounds
the two contrasting forces are seemingly
meant to have their final showdown and
they more than exceed
expectations with this fight after a
long drawn-out fight that has no
shortage of drama and tension nanashi
finally overcomes the seemingly
unbeatable foe and wins against luo lang
the cinematography and presentation
really drove this fight up a notch a lot
of people expected a standard sword
fight with sprinkles of drama
but got more than what they bargained
for if you need another reason to watch
sword of the stranger
may this fight be it
[Music]
and finally topping the list is none
other than a fight from one of the best
arcs in shonen
meruem vs nataero nadero's death in
battle against meruem
is probably one of any hunter hunter
fans top moments in the series
in this fight someone as powerful as the
kimira and king finally finds an
opponent that can stand up to his
strength standing across him is the
hunter chairman himself and the two
tore the house down with the showcase of
their powers in the end it was nadero
who was dealt a fatal blow after a very
long showdown
meruem even survived nadero's
desperation attack
zero hand victory didn't come easy
though and there's no time for
celebration
especially after having the entire field
blown up by poor man's rose afterwards
there are many things to take away from
the kimura antarct
it's not known as one of the best arcs
in an entire genre for nothing
you've got amazing villains some great
story beats
one of the most memorable moments we got
out of gone
and then we have this the two got an
entire episode for themselves for crying
out loud
it's truly a work of art
it seems that contrary to popular belief
death isn't cheap at all in the world of
anime i heard from some people that
character death when used properly is
one of the most powerful
motivators that drive another character
or plot to go forward
given the entries we have on the list
i'd agree with that statement
how about you do you agree or disagree
do you have other fights that you'd love
to see on this list comment down below
and
introduce me to those classic moments
that you've seen in anime don't forget
to check out our sponsors
summoners war the links in the
description i'll be leaving you with
that for now and i hope to see you next
time around
you